‏more
anday
littleer and you have superancy special
right superancy special so we will be
having that as well also the qu compe i
want to dri this home the qu compe is
important the reg is whatsapp
announcement
‏compise
and
comp
in good things
of prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
انء اللهالى
‏will
as well andesite
up
youum
‏You
you could on the throne.
305.
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران
هدى للناس وبينات من بينات من الهدى
والفرقان
فمن شهد منكم الشهر فليصم
ومن كان مريضا او على سفر فعده من ايام
اخر يريد الله بكم اليسر ولا يريد بكم
العسر ولتكملوا العده ولتكبروا الله على
ما هداكم
ولعلكم
تشكرون
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسوله النبي الكريم رب اشرح لي صدري
ويسر لي امري واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه
قولي سبحان
‏diving
to grow leaps and bs and so the reason I
want to start with this particular one
of my things to do as go throughران
try my best says
القران لذكري فهل من مد
as الله سبحانه وتالى
‏easy any take time
and so as go through this in the next
time I have with you I want toare a few
fleeting reflections and this is first
and for me and for myself alone and ins
I'm hing toare them with you as well so
taking a kind of the way that I kind of
look at this I kind of see it in three
parts the first part is particularly
‏that through you is everlasting good
you is everlasting good and so the first
part of this first part of this the way
that the way that it resonates with me
is that Allah subhanah is saying that it
is in this month in this holy month of
thatan in the enti quan is only mention
once
الله سبحانه وتالى
شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران هدى للناس
مذكب لابقين
‏unal
guance notl not
gu
‏and
life
الله
ourciine our fa and bring
and go our noral da lives areble to kind
the hum ‏that
that this month teaches to us and some
the greatest in hisory in particular in
Islamic they were also done in Ramadan
Ramadan is not a month in which we spend
all night in the hook lunges in staying
up all night and drinkingofe
and spending the rest of the time asleep
and wing up 3 minut at a time
عصب
our
was
inان
also was the of was also in in the
battle of angel
that coming all the way fromal as there
was nothing sting them
حمين
সুল্লাহ সুনাল্লাহ
people
are
not
‏this is
gu all man notesar
[Silence]
guow
‏would not
was darkness we would not happ andy and
pride if was not andp
and
that isility to be able to differate
that is what theران is and that is why
it is that we are celebrating
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
[Silence]
بكم
ولا يريد بكمر
[Silence]
‏translation
because anyone langage and a langage if
you tr to
that for you would
بسم اللهم
بسم الله
name الله
بسم
الله
سبحان الله
[Silence]
‏usoverwa
is what god consciousness
what it means to look at our parched
throats and look at our chning bellies
and to look at our leury and say
ন ক্রোল me ক্রমা
তাকওয়া myness
அal
me will
f and my ownake
‏owners
anything you to
doves
involves
and
right medical scho is not easy a small
and being call 247 is not
‏you have some
beauful
lives you have a place
to use make
سبحان الله সু الله
[Silence]
ولعكم تشكرون
‏all
you will have to be thankful to
make those people are thankful
are thanful
to
the best of us and may all us to curse
and debate the
اللهم ربنا منهم جزاكم الله
جزاك الله قولي هذا واستغفر الله
جزاكم الله خيرا بارك الله فيكم
صلاه
تراويح ان شاء الله جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
بسم
الله
[Silence]
نعم شغال ولا لا شغال
منك ايتين هاخد منك ايتين
[Arabic recitation]
سووا الصف سدوا الخلل
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقدموا بين يدي
الله ورسوله واتقوا الله واتقوا الله ان
الله سميع عليم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا ترفعوا اصواتكم
فوق صوت النبي ولا تجهروا له بالقول كجهر
بعضكم لبعض
ان تحبط اعمالكم وانتم لا تشعرون
ان الذين يغضون اصواتهم عند رسول الله
اولئك
اولئك الذين امتحن الله قلوبهم للتقوى
لهم مغفره
واجر عظيم
ان الذين ينادونك من وراء الحجرات اكثرهم
لا يعقلون
ولو انهم صبروا حتى تخرج اليهم لكان خيرا
لهم والله غفور رحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان جاءكم
فاسق بنبا فتبينوا
فتبينوا ان تصيبوا قوما بجهاله له فتصبحوا
على ما فعلتم نادمين
واعلموا ان فيكم رسول الله
لو يطيعكم في كثير من الامر لعندتم
ولكن
حبب اليكم الايمان وزينه في قلوبكم
وزينه في قلوبكم وكره اليك كم الكفر
والفسوق والعصيان
اولئك
هم الراشدون
فضلا من الله ونعمه والله عليم حكيم
وان طائفتان
من المؤمنين اقتتلوا فاصلحوا بينهما
فان بغت احداهما
على الاخرى فقاتلوا التي تبغي حتى تفيء
الى امر الله
فان فاءت فاصلحوا بينهما بالعدل واقسطوا
ان الله يحب المقسطين
انما
المؤمنون اخوه
فاصلحوا بين اخويكم واتقوا الله لعلكم
ترحمون.
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يسخر قوم من قوم
عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم
عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم ولا نساء
من نساء
عسى
عسى ان يكون خيرا منهم
ولا تلمزوا انفسكم ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب
بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد الايمان
ومن لم يتب فاولئك
هم الظالمون
يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من
الظن
ان بعض الظن
اثم ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
ايحب احدكم ان ياكل لحم اخيه ميتا
فكرهتموه
واتقوا الله ان الله تواب رحيم
يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم
من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل
لتعارفوه
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم
ان الله عليم خبير
قالت الاعراب امنا قل لم تؤمنوا ولكن
قولوا اسلمنا
ولكن قولوا اسلمنا ولما يدخل الايمان في
قلوبكم
وان تطيعوا الله ورسوله لا يلدكم من
اعمالكم شيئا
ان الله غفور والله غفور رحيم
ان الله غفور رحيم رحيم انما المؤمنون
الذين امنوا بالله ورسوله وجاهدوا
باموالهم
انما المؤمنون الذين
امنوا بالله ورسوله ثم لم يرتابوا
ثم لم يرتابوا
وجاهدوا باموالهم وانفسهم
في سبيل الله
اولئك
هم الصادقون
قل اتعلمون الله بدينكم
والله يعلم ما في السماوات وما في الارض
والله بكل شيء عليم
يمنون
عليك ان اسلموا
قل لا تمنوا
علي اسلامكم
بل الله يمن
عليكم ان هداكم للاسلام
عليكم هداكم للايمان
بل الله يمن عليكم ان هداكم للايمان ان
كنتم
صادقين
ان الله يعلم غيب السماوات والارض
والله بصير
بما تعملون
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قاف
والقران المجيد
بل عجبوا ان جاءهم
منذر منهم فقال الكافرون هذا شيء عجيب
ائذا متنا وكنا
ترابا ذلك رجع بعيد
قد علمنا ما تنقص الارض منهم وعندنا كتاب
حفيظ
بل كذبوا بالحق لما جاءهم
فهم في امر مريج
افلم ينظروا الى السماء
فوقهم كيف بنيناها وزيناها
وزيناها
وما لها من فروج
والارض مددناها والقينا
فيها رواسي وانبتنا
فيها
وانبتنا فيها من كل زوج بهيج
تبصره وذكرى لكل عبد منيب
ونزلنا من السماء
ماء
مباركا
فانب تنا به جنات
وحب الحصيد
والنخل باسطات لها طلع مضيد
رزقا للعباد واحيينا به بلده
ميتا
كذلك الخروج
كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح واصحاب الرس وثمود
وعاد وفرعون واخوان لوط
واصحاب الايكه وقوم تبع
كل
كذب الرسل فحق وعيد
افعينا بالخلق الاول بل هم في لبس من خلق
جديد
ولقد خلقنا الانسان ونعلم ما توسوس به
نفسه ونحن اقرب اليه من حبل الوريد
اذ يتلقى المتلقيان عن اليمين وعن الشمال
قعيد
ما يلفظ من قول الا لديه رقيب عتيد
وجاءت
سك سره الموت بالحق ذلك ما كنت منه تحيد
ونفخ في الصور ذلك يوم الوعيد
وجاءت كل نفس معها سائق
وشهيد
لقد كنت في غفله من هذا فكشفنا
عنك غط غطاءك
فكشفنا عنك غطاءك
فبصرك اليوم حديد
وقال قرينه هذا ما لدي عتيد
القيا في جهنم
كل جبار عنيد
القيا في جهنم كل كفار عنيد
مناع
للخير معتد مريب
الذي جعل مع الله الها اخر
فالقياه في العذاب الشديد
قال قرينه ربنا ما اطغيته ولكن كان في
ضلال بعيد
قال لا تختصموا لدي وقد قدمت اليكم
بالوعيد
ما يبدل القول لدي
ما يبدل القول لدي وما انا بظلام للعبيد
ويوم نقول لجهنم
هل امتلات وتقول
وتقول هل من مزي
وازلت الجنه
للمتقين غير بعيد
هذا ما توعدون لكل اواب حفيظ
من خشي الرحمن بالغيب وجاء بقلب منب
ادخلوها بسلام
ذلك يوم الخلود
لهم ما يشاؤون
فيها ولدينا مزيد
وكم اهلكنا قبلهم من قرن هم اشد منهم
بطشاه
فنقبوا في البلاد هل من محيص
ان في ذلك لذكرى
ان في ذلك لذكرى لمن كان له قلب
او القى السمع وهو شهيد
ولقد خلقنا السماوات والارض وما بينهما في
سته ايام وما مسنا من الغوب
فاصبر على ما يقولون وسبح بحمد ربك قبل
طلوع الشمس وقبل الغروب
ومن الليل فسبحه واد ادبار السجود
واستمع يوم ينادي المنادي من
مكان قريب
يوم يسمعون الصيحه بالحق
ذلك يوم الخروج
انا
نحن نحيي ونميت والينا المصير
يوم تشقق الارض عنهم سراعا
ذلك حشر علينا يسير
نحن اعلم بما يقولون وما انت عليهم بجبار
فذكر بالقران
من
يخاف وعيد
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏uglistenam
and
right here
not only that if your to the and not
them ‏is place
in here ever what is point of coming to
the what is just another building or do
we respect the library and yoga
studio more than we do the this is not
okay
pleas pleas your children are in the
baby sitting in the gym
‏have
not
pleas make
[Silence]
لانه انا وراك
استقيموا اعتدلوا
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والذاريات ذروا فالحاملات وقرا فالجاريات
يسرا فالمقسمات
امرا انما توعدون لصادق
ان الدين لواقع
والسماء ذات الحبك انكم لفي قول مختلف
يؤفك عنه من افك قتل الخراصون
الذين هم في غمره ساهون
يسالون ايان يوم الدين يومهم على النار
يفتنون
ذوق قوا فتنتكم هذا الذي كنتم
به تستعجلون
ان المتقين في جنات
وعيون
اخذين ما
اتاهم ربهم
انهم كانوا قبل ذلك محسنين
كانوا قليلا من الليل لما يهجعون
وبالاسحار هم يستغفرون
وفي اموالهم حق للسائل
والمحروم
وفي الارض ايات للموقنين
وفي انفسكم
افلا تبصرون
وفي السماء
رزقكم وما توعدون
فور رب السماء والارض انه
لحق
انه لحق مثلما انكم تنطقون
هل اتاك حديث ضيف ابراهيم المكرمين
اذ دخلوا عليه فقالوا سلاما قال سلام
قال سلام قوم
منكرون
فراغ الى اهله فجاء بعجل سمير
فقربه اليهم قال الا تاكلون
فاوجس منهم خيفه قالوا لا تخف وبشروه
بغلام عليم
فاقبلت
في سروه فصكت ت وجهها
وقالت عجوز عقيم
قالوا كذلك قال ربك انه هو الحكيم العليم
قال فما خطبكم ايها المرسلون
قالوا انا ارسلنا الى قوم مجرمين
لنرسل عليهم حجاره
من طين مسومه عند ربك للمسركين
فما وجدنا فيها غير بيت من المؤمن فما
وجدنا فيها
فاخرجنا من كان فيها من المؤمنين
فما وجدنا فيها غير بيت من المسلمين
وتركنا فيها ايه للذين يخافون العذاب
الاليم
وفي موسى اذ ارسلناه الى فرعون بسلطان
مبين
فتولى بركنه وقال ساحر او مجنون
فاخذناه وجنوده فنبذناهم
في اليم
وهو ميم
وفي عاد اذ ارسلنا عليه مريح العقيم
ما تذر من شيء اتت عليه الا
جعلته كالميم
وفي ثمود اذ قيل لهم تمتعوا حتى حين
فعتوا عن امر ربهم
فاخذتهم الصاعقه وهم ينظرون
فما استطاعوا من قيام وما كانوا منتصرين
وقوم نوح من قبل انهم
انهم
كانوا قوما
فاسقين
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والسماء
بني ناها بايد وانا لموسعون
والارض فرشناها فنعم الماهدون
ومن كل شيء خلقنا زوجين لعلكم تذكرون
ففروا الى الله انني لكم منه نذير مبين
ولا تجعلوا مع الله الها اخر اني
لكم منه نذير مبين
كذلك ما اتى الذين من قبلهم من رسول الا
قالوا ساحر او مجنون
اتواصوا به بل هم قوم طاغون
فتولى عنهم فما
ان تملون
وذكر فان الذكرى تنفع المؤمنين
وما خلقت الجن والانس الا ليعبدون
ما اريد منهم من رزق
وما اريد ان يطعمون
ان الله هو الرزاق ذو القوه المتين
فان للذين ظلموا ذنوبا مثل ذنوب اصحابهم
فلا يستعجلون
فويل للذين كفروا من يومهم الذي يعدون
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والطور وكتاب مستور في رق منشور
والبيت المعمور
والبيت المعمور والسقف المرفوع والبحر
المسجور
ان عذاب ربك لواقع
ما له من دافع يوم تموت
السماء نورا وتسير الجبال سيرا
فويل يومئذ للمكذبين
الذين هم في خوض يلعبون
يوم يدعون الى نار جهنم
دعاه
هذه النار التي كنتم بها تكذبون
افسحر هذا ام انتم لا تبصرون
اصلوها فاصبروا او لا تصبروا سواء
عليكم
انما
تجزون ما كنتم تعملون
ان المتقين في جنات
و في جنات
النعيم
ان المتقين في جنات
ونعيم
فاكهين بما اتاهم ربهم
ووقاهم ربهم عذاب الجحيم
كلوا واشربوا هنيئا
بما كنتم تعملون
متكئين على سرر مصفوفه
وزوج وجناهم بحور عين
والذين امنوا واتبعتهم ذريتهم
بايمان الحقنا بهم ذريتهم
الحقنا بهم ذريتهم وما التناهم من عملهم
من شيء كل امر بما كسب رهينه
وامددناهم
بفاك
ولحم
ما يشتهون
يتنازعون فيها كاسا لا له فيها ولا تاثير
ويطوف عليهم غلمان لهم كانهم لؤلؤ مكنون
واقبل بعضهم على بعض يتساءلون
قالوا انا كن انا قبل في اهلنا مشفقين
فمن
الله علينا ووقانا عذاب السموم
انا كنا من قبل ندعوه
انه
هو البر الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
That's why
I hope you
thank you from you.
[Silence]
سنتين
الروم
‏try
[Silence]
‏I think you can
so
[Silence]
that is
يعطيك العافيه
[Silence]
تعال
حاجه
[Silence]
حسن
استووا واعتدلوا
استووا
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
فذكر فما انت بنعمه ربك بكاهن
ولا مجنون ام يقولون شاعر نتربص به ريب
المنون قل تربصوا فاني معكم من المتربصين
ام تامرهم هم احلامهم
بهذا ام هم قوم طاغون
ام يقولون تقوله بل لا يؤمنون فلياتوا
بحديث مثله ان كانوا صادقين
ام خلقوا من غير شيء ام هم الخالقون
ام خلقوا السماوات والارض بل لا يوقنون
ام عندهم خز زائل ربك ام هم المسيطرون
ام لهم سلم
يستمعون فيه فليات مستمعهم بسلطان مبين
ام لكم ام له البنات ولكم البنون ام
تسالهم اجرا فهم من مغرب مثقلون ام عندهم
الغيب فهم يكتبون
ام يريدون كيدا فالذين كفروا هم المكيدون
ام لهم اله غير الله
سبحان الله عما يشركون
وان يروا كسفا من السماء ساقطا يقولوا
سحاب مركوم
فذرهم حتى يلاقوا يومهم الذي فيه يصعقون
يوم لا يغني عنهم كيدهم شيئا ولا هم
ينصرون
وان للذين ظلموا عذابا دون ذلك ولكن
اكثرهم لا يعلمون
واصبر لحكم ربك فانك
باعيننا
وسبح بحمد ربك حين تقوم
ومن الليل فسبحه وادبار النجوم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والنجم
اذا هوى ما ضل صاحبكم وما غوى وما ينطق عن
الهوى ان هو الا وحي يوحى علمه شديد القوى
ذو مره فاستوى وهو بالافق الاعلى ثم دنى
فتدلى فكان قاب قوسين او ادنى فاوحى الى
عبده ما اوحى ما كذب الفؤاد ما راى
افتمارونه
على ما يرى ولقد راه نزله اخرى عند سدره
المنتهى
عندها جنه
الماوى اذ يغشى السدره ما يغشى ما زاغ
البصر وما طغى لقد راى من ايات ربه الكبرى
افرايتم اللات والعزا ومنات الثالثه
الاخرى الكم الذكر وله الانثى تلك اذا
قسمه
ضيزا
ان هي الا اسماء
سميتموها
انتم واباؤكم
ما انزل الله بها من سلطان
ان يتبعون الا الظن وما تهوى الانفس ولقد
جاءهم
من ربهم الهدى
ام للانسان
ما تمنى فلله الاخره ره والاولى وكم من
ملك في السماوات لا تغني شفاعتهم شيئا الا
من بعد ان ياذن الله
الا من بعد ان ياذن الله لمن يشاء ويرضى
ان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره ليسمون
الملائكه
تسميه انثى
وما لهم به من علم ان يتبعون الا الظن
وان الظن لا يغني من الحق شيئا فاعرض عمن
تولى عن ذكرنا ولم يرد الا الحياه الدنيا
ذلك مبلغهم
من العلم ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله
وهو اعلم بمن اهتدى
ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض ليجزي
الذين اساءوا
بما عملوا ويجزي الذين احسنوا بالحسنى
الذين يجتنبون كبائر
الاثم والفواحش الا اللمم ان ربك واسع
المغفره هو اعلم بكم اذ انشاكم
من الارض واذ انتم اجنه
في بطون امهاتكم
فلا تزكوا انفسكم
هو اعلم بمن اتقى
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
افرايت الذي تولى واعطى قليلا واكدى اعنده
علم الغيب فهو يرى ام لم ينبا بما في صحف
موسى وابراهيم الذي وفى الا تزر وازره وزر
اخرى وان ليس للانسان
الا ما سعى وان سعيه سوف يرى ثم يجزاه
الجزاء
الاوفى
وان الى ربك المنتهى
وانه هو اضحك وابكى وانه هو امات واحيا
وانه خلق الزوجين الذكر والانثى
من نطفه اذا تمنى وان عليه النشاه الاخرى
وانه هو اغنى واقنى وانه هو رب الشعرا
وانه
اهلك عاد الاولى وثمود فما ابقى وقوم نوح
من قبل انهم كانوا هم اظلم واطغى والمؤ
متفكه اهوى فغشاها ما غشا فباي الاء
ربك تتمارى
هذا نذير
من النذر الاولى ازفه الازفه
ليس لها من دون الله كاشفه
افمن هذا الحديث تعجبون
وتضحكون ولا تبكون
وانتم سامدون
فاسجدوا لله واعبدوه
الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اقتربت الساعه
وانشق
القمر وان يروا ايه يعرضوا ويقولوا سحر
مستمر
وكذبوا واتبعوا اهواءهم
وكل امر مستقر
ولقد جاءهم من الانباء ما فيه مزدجر حكمه
بالغه فما تغني النذر
فتولى عنهم يوم يدعو الداع الى شيء نكر خش
عن ابصارهم يخرجون من الاجداث كانهم جراد
منتشر مهطعين الى الداع يقول الكافرون هذا
يوم عسر كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح فكذبوا عبدنا
وقالوا مجنون وازدجر فدعا ربه اني مغلوب
فانتصر ففتحنا ابواب السماء بماء
منهمر وفجرنا الارض عيونا فالتقى الماء
على امر قد قدر
وحملناه على ذات الواح ودثر تجري باعيننا
جزاء
لمن كان كفر ولقد تركناها ايه فهل
مدكر فكيف كان عذابي ونذر ولقد يسرنا
القران للذكر فهل من مدكر
كذبت عاد فكيف كان عذابي ونذر انا ارسلنا
عليهم ريحا صرصرا في يوم نحس مستمر
تنزع الناس كانهم اعجاز نخل منقعر فكيف
كان عذابي ونذر ولقد يسرنا القران للذكر
فهل من مدكر
كذبت ثمود بالنذر فقالوا ابشر منا واحدا
نتبعه انا اذا لفي ضلال وسعر االقي الذكر
عليه من بيننا بل هو كذاب اشير سيعلمون
غدا من الكذاب
الاش انا مرسل الناقه فتنه لهم فارتقبهم
واصطبر ونبئهم ان الماء قسمه بينهم كل شرب
محتضر فنادوا صاحبهم فتعاطى فعقر فكيف كان
عذابي ونذر
انا ارسلنا عليهم انا ارسلنا عليهم حاصبا
فكانوا كهشيم المحتظر
انا ارسلنا عليهم صيحه واحده فكانوا كهشيم
المحتظر ولقد يسرنا القران للذكر فهل من
مدكر
كذبت قوم لوط بالنذر
انا ارسلنا عليهم حاصبا الا ال لوط
نجيناهم
بسحر نعمه من عندنا
نعمه من عندنا كذلك نجزي من شكر ولقد
انذرهم بطشتنا فتماروا بالنذر ولقد راودوه
عن ضيفه فطمسنا اعينهم فطمسنا اعينهم
فذوقوا عذابي ونذر ولقد صبحهم بكره
عذاب مستقر
فذوقوا عذابي ونذر ولقد يسرنا القران
للذكر فهل من مدكر
ولقد جاء ال فرعون النذر كذبوا باياتنا
كلها فاخذناهم اخذ عزيز مقتدر اكفاركم خير
من اولئكم
ام لكم براءه
في الزبر
ام يقولون نحن جميع منتصر سيهزم الجمع
ويولون الدبر بل الساعه موعدهم والساعه
ادهى وامر
ان المجرمين في ضلال وسعر يوم يسحبون في
النار على وجوههم ذوقوا مس سقر انا كل شيء
خلقناه بقدر وما امرنا الا واحده كلمح
بالبصر
ولقد اهلكنا اشياعكم فهل من مدكر وكل شيء
فعلوه في الزبر وكل صغير وكبير
مستطر ان المتقين في جنات
ونهر في مقعد صدق عند مليت
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الرحمن
علم قران
خلق الانسان علمه البيان
الشمس والقمر بحسبان والنجم والشجر يسجدان
والسماء
رفعها ووضع الميزان الا تطغوا في الميزان
واقيموا الوزن بالقسط ولا تخسروا الميزان
والارض وضعها للانام فيها فاكهه والنخ خل
ذات الاكمام
والحب ذو العصف والريحان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
خلق الانسان من صلصال كالفخار
وخلق الجان
من مارج من نار
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
رب المشرقين ورب المغربين فباي الاء ربكما
تكذبان
مرج البحرين يلتقيان
بينهما برزخ لا يبغيان فباي الاء ربكما
تكذبان
يخرج منهما اللؤلؤ والمرجان فباي الاء
ربكما تكذبان
وله الجوار المنشات في البحر كالاعلام
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
كل من عليها فان
ويبقى وجه ربك ذو الجلال والاكرام
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
يساله من في السماوات والارض كل يوم هو في
شان فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
سنفرغ لكم ايها الثقلان
فباي الاء
ربكما تكذبان
يا معشر الجن والانس ان استطعتم ان تنفذوا
من اقطار السماوات والارض فانفذوا
فانفذوا لا تنفذون الا بسلطان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
يرسل عليكما شواظ من نار ونحاس فلا
تنتصران
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
فاذا انشقت السماء فكانت ورده كالدهان
فب باي الاء ربكما تكذبان
فيومئذ لا يسال عن ذنبه انس ولا جان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
يعرف المجرمون بسيماهم فيؤخذ بالنواصي
والاقدام
فباي الاء ربكما تكذب
هذه جهنم التي يكذب بها المجرمون يطوفون
بينها وبين حميم ان فباي الاء ربكما
تكذبان
ولمن خاف مقام ربه جنتان فباي الاء ربكما
ذواتا افنان فباي الاء
ربكما تكذبان
فيهما عينان تجريان فباي الاءء ربكما
تكذبان
فيهما من كل فاكهه زوجان فباي الاء ربكما
متكئين على فرش بطائنها
من استبرق وجن الجن جنتين دان فباي الاء
ربكما تكذبان
فيهن قاصرات الطرف لم يطمثهن انس قبلهم
ولا جان
فباي الاء
ربكما تكذبان
كانهن
الياقوت والمرجان فباي الاء
ربكم ما تكذبان
هل جزاء الاحسان الا الاحسان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
ومن دونهما جنتان
مدهامتان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
فيهما عينان نضاختان فباي الاء ربكما
تكذبان
فيهما فاكهه ونخل ورمان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
فيهن خيرات حسان فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
ان
حور مقصورات
في الخيام
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
لم يطمثهن انس قبلهم ولا جان
متكئين على رفرف خضر وعبقري
حسان
فباي الاء ربكما تكذبان
تبارك اسم ربك ذي الجلال والاكرام
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهد اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اذا وقعت الواقعه
ليس لوقعتها كاذبه خافضه رافعه اذا رجت
الارض رجا وبست الجبال بسا فكانت هباء
منبثا
وكنتم ازواجا ثلاثه فاصحاب الميمنه ما
اصحاب الميمنه واصحاب المشامه ما اصحاب
المشامه والسابقون السابقون
اولئك
المقربون
في جنات النعيم
ثله من الاولين وقليل من الاخرين
على سرر موضونه متكئين عليها متقابلين
يطوف عليهم ولدان مخلدون باكواب واباريق
وكاس من معين لا يصدعون عنها ولا ينزفون
وفاكهه مما يتخيرون ولحم طير مما يشتهون
وحور عين وحور عين كامثال اللؤلؤ المكنون
جزاء بما كانوا يعملون
لا يسمعون فيها لغوا ولا تاثيما
الا قيلا سلاما سلاما واصحاب اليمين ما
اصحاب اليمين
في سدر مخضود وطلح منضود
وظل ممدود
وماء
مسكوب وفاكهه كثيره لا مقطوعه ولا ممنوعه
وفرش مرفوعه انا انشاناهن
ان شاءناهن
انشاء
فجعلناهن
ابكارا عربا اترابا لاصحاب اليمين
ثله من الاولين وثله من الاخرين
واصحاب الشمال ما اصحاب الشمال
في سموم وحميم
وظل من يحموم لا بارد ولا كريم
انهم كانوا قبل ذلك مترفين
وكانوا يصرون على الحنث العظيم وكانوا
يقولون ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا وعظاما اانا
لمبعوثون
اوباؤنا
الاولون
قل ان الاولين والاخرين لمجموعون الى
ميقات يوم معلوم
ثم انكم ايها الضالون
المكذبون
لاكلون من شجر من زقوم فمالئون منها
البطون فشاربون عليه من الحميم فشاربون
شرب بلهيم
هذا نزلهم يوم الدين
نحن خلقناكم فلولا تصدقون
افرايتم ما تمنون
اانتم تخلقونه ام نحن الخالقون
نحن قدرنا بينكم الموت وما نحن بمسبوقين
على ان نبدل امثالكم وننشئكم فيما لا
تعلمون
ولقد علمتم النشاه الاولى فلولا تذكرون
افرايتم
ما تزرعون
افرايتم ما تحرثون
اانتم تزرعونه ام نحن الزارعون
لو نشاء لجعلناه حطاما فظلتم م تفكهون
انا لمغرمون بل نحن محرومون
افرايتم الماء الذي تشربون اانتم انزلتموه
من المزن ام نحن المنزلون
لو نشاء جعلناه اجاجا فلولا تشكرون
افرايتم النار التي تورون
اانتم انشاتم شجرتها ام نحن المنشئون
نحن جعلناها تذكره ومتاعا للمقوين
فسبح باسم ربك العظيم
سبحان
فلا اقسم بمواقع النجوم
وانه لقسم لو تعلمون عظيم انه لقران قران
كريم في كتاب مكنون لا يمسه الا المطهرون
تنزيل من رب العالمين
افبهذا الحديث انتم مدهنون
وتجعلون رزقكم انكم تكذبون
فلولا اذا بلغت الحلقوم
وانتم حينئذ تنظرون
ونحن اقرب اليه منكم
ونحن اقرب اليه منكم ولكن لا تبصرون
فلولا ان كنتم غير مدينين ترجعونها ان
كنتم صادقين
فاما ان كان من المقربين
فروح وريحان وجنه نعيم
واما ان كان من اصحاب اليمين فسلام لك من
اصحاب اليمين
واما ان كان من المكذبين الضالين
فنزل من حميم
وتصليه جحيم
ان هذا لهو حق اليقين
فسب سبح باسم ربك العظيم
سبحان ربي العظيم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استووا اعتدلوا
وتر صلاه والشفع والوتر
الله
اكبر سبحانك وبحمد
جن
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
ايا اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
واخرجت الارض اثقالها
وقال الانسان
ما لها
يومئذ
تحدث اخبارها
بان
ربك
اوحى لها
يومئذ
يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يره ومن يعمل
مثقال ذره
شرا
يره
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان ربي ان سبحان ربي سبحان رب
الله
اكبر
اكبر سبحان ربنا سبحان ربنا
سبحان ربنا سبحان
الله
اكبر بسم بسم الله الرحمن
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت ت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الهاكم التكاثر
الهاكم التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا لا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسال
ن يومئذ عن النعيم
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان ربي سبحان الله رب سبحان
الله
اكبر
سبحان ربي سبحان رب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن
توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
انك حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد
وعلى
محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى
ال ابراهيم
في العالمين
انك حميد مجيد
ربنا لك الحمد حتى ترضى ولك الحمد اذا
رضيت
ولك الحمد بعد الرضا
لك الحمد على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض لك
الحمد انت قيوم السماوات والارض اللهم
اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا وبين
معصيتك
ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب
الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا
ما
احييتنا
واجعله الوارث منا
واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا
وانصرنا
على من عادانا
اللهم اصلح لنا ديننا
الذي هو عصمه امرنا اللهم اصلح لنا دنيانا
التي فيها معاشنا
اللهم اجعل خير اعمارنا اواخره
اللهم اجعل خير ايامنا يوم نلقاك فيه
يوم نلقاك فيه
ربنا لا تحرمنا من لذه النظر الى وجهك
ومجالسه نبيك والجمع بيننا في جنتك
اللهم اجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وجعلنا من التالين له القارئين له اطراف
النهار
اناء
الليل
واجعله بيننا وبينك حجه لنا شافعا
مشفعا
فينا
ولا تجعل القران حجه علينا اللهم ارزقنا
القران
اللهم
ارزقنا القران
لين به قلوبنا
ورتب به السنتنا
واصلح به احيا واصلح به احوالنا
اللهم اننا نسالك موجبات رحمتك وعزائم
مغفرتك
والغنيمه من كل بر والفوز بالجنات
النجاه والسلامه من كل اثم والفوز بالجنه
والفوز بالجنه
والنجاه
من النار
اللهم احفظ المسجد الاقصى بحفظك وارعاه
برعايتك
واحرسه بعينك التي لا تنام
اللهم من اراد هذه الامه بشر فعليك به
نجعلك في نحورهم
ونعوذ بك من شرورهم
اللهم من اراد احدا من هذه الامه بشر
فعليك به واجعل تدمير
تدبيره تدميرا
واجعل تدبيره
تدميرا
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم عليك بعدونا وعدوك ك اعداء الدين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
فانه قد عاث في الارض فسادا
وسفك الدماء
وجعل الناس في ريبه من امرهم اللهم
عليك به وباهله اللهم اللهم زلزل اركانه
وصدع بنيانه
واقتل اجناده
واقذف في قلوب اهله الهلع والفزع والذله
واضرب عليهم الصغار حيث حلوا
واجعل قتلاهم في النيران
واجعل قتلانا في الجنان
شهداء
عندك
في حواصل طير خضر في اشجار الجنه
ربنا انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين
في غزه وفلسطين
وفي السودان وفي كشمير
وفي الشام والعراق
وفي اليمن يا رب العالمين
اللهم انصرهم
على عدوهم
واجعلهم على من عاداهم ظاهرين
قاهرين
منصورين
عالمين
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
سبحان ربي سبحان ربنا سبحان ربنا
الله
اكبر
سبحان
الله
احبار
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
رب الملائكه
والروح
[Arabic recitation]